hi
i'm edie patterson and i'll be taking
you on a tour behind the scenes of the
righteous
gemstones
this is brian moss he like super loves
doing my hair
thanks darling thank you
tonight anything's fine
is that normal
uh no but i don't really question it
work a lot of late nights sometimes all
the way through the night so i come to
see my friend will at crafty i would
love a wagyu beef and maine lobster
slider thanks so much
okay thanks
everyone gets tipped
you
if you've watched the show you know that
my dude is played by tim baltz let's hit
him up it was good for paul
oh hey are we back from lunch i was just
gonna see if you want to do some lines
but we don't have to right now oh cool
okay well i'll see you back out there
the character of bj is actually played
by an ai
hbo spent a ton of money
on it but i it does a great job clearly
real life westworld
anyway
so next we'll go say hi to um my friend
cassidy she plays amber on the show
she's like gorgeous graceful like she's
really classy
oh hey girl
sorry my shitter's clogging it smells
terrible in there it was just um
telling some of these guys about my life
here at the gym stream
it's a good life right except when your
shutter is broken yeah i'm sorry to hear
that it's okay yeah no it's fine i just
got a drip drip dryer no i know yeah i
know it's primed for you but i feel like
i have some splashes oh did you
anyway okay okay yeah i'm sorry my hands
wet yep it's really wet jesus turned the
water into one there's your tip for the
day thanks you gotta tip everybody out
thanks for today thanks for doing a
scene with me today thanks for filming
me it costs a ton to be on a tv show but
it's a price you pay
greg allen thanks for joining us with me
you sure yeah thanks
jesus
every now and then they're locked
you